Busca renovar su política así como you
smaya quien eligió el único partido del
país dirigido por una mujer para ella
las mujeres siguen estando sub
representadas en la Esfera política del
país a las mujeres les resulta difícil
involucrarse en política nos guste o no
los hombres todavía no tienen agarradas
pero trabajaremos para romper estos
códigos y es por eso que me postulo para
el cargo las mujeres ocupan actualmente
el 7% de los escaños de la asamblea
nacional sin embargo el nuevo parlamento
reserva el 22% de los escaños para
mujeres con un mínimo de una mujer por
Distrito electoral pero la joven cabeza
de lista no se considera una defensora
de la cuota femenina
me voy a ir allí para que las cosas
puedan cambiar en la sociedad civil
estamos conscientes de las necesidades
de la comunidad y eso en la asamblea
nacional donde se votan las leyes para
satisfacer estas necesidades
el candidato a diputado León kojude
asegura que salió de las Sombras e
ingresó a la política para mejorar la
calidad de vida de las comunidades
[Música]
detrás de escena de algunos consejos a
los políticos a los funcionarios electos
pero desafortunadamente descubrí que
siempre había esta brecha entre la gente
y los políticos
la populación
eligió un partido que se presentó por
primera vez y pertenece al movimiento
presidencial pero que asegura a jugar
por nuevas caras en la asamblea nacional
la población estas personas dicen que ya
no quieren parlamentarios ausentes en
sus áreas Rurales
dicen que ya no quieren diputados a los
que no les importe estar cerca de sus
electores dicen que ya no quieren
diputados que una vez elegidos dan la
espalda a la población
para este recién llegado a la política
la Selección del legislativas son una
oportunidad para poner fin a una
asamblea nacional controlada
exclusivamente por el partido
presidencial
se imaginan que en funcionarios que para
votar por una ley levantan el dedo
aunque no estén de acuerdo y todos votan
por esta ley nosotros decimos que no
estamos de acuerdo con esta ley por
ellos todavía pero ellos todavía lo
hacen por el miedo
en las elecciones legislativas
anteriores Sólo dos partidos
presidenciales pudieron participar esta
vez siete partidos están en la carrera
tres de los cuales son partidos de
oposición